Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[music]
I bring to you the greeting of peace,
the greeting of the old prophets.
I Kamurin Abdullah born in 1968 in
Penang Malaysia born as a Christian and
a churchgoer attended Sunday schools and
alhamdulillah in the age of 18 years old
Allah subhana wa ta'ala blessed me with
the greatest gift AlI Islam
alhamdulillah
as a Christian who looking for God
alhamdulillah I found the answer in the
Holy Quran unfortunately there were no
Muslim to share Islam to me. That was
the fire today to share the greatest
sunnah of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam to share Islam to all human
being respected Dr. Zakir night.
Alhamdulillah I hosted him in 1998 in
Paneang. Mashallah
and alhamdulillah after accepting Islam
in 1992 I started the ATMT which is the
most tour in Masidang
where our beloved Dr.
I've delivered in Pinang Masid
alhamdulillah thousands of people it's
already 25 years I'm doing that and in
1990 I met the late she Ahmedat rahimah
where I met him alhamdulillah I was that
time I was have doubts about prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
he given me a book called what the bible
says about Muhammad after giving that
book he said to me you read it and you
share to your friends and your relative
if you do not do so you are useless so
in In three four years back I went to
South Africa to deliver my lecture and I
tell the audience this story of meeting
him and I tell him that today I'm useful
because of the fire of Ahmed say if you
do not deliver your job you are useless
and that was make me until today useful
alhamdulillah and alhamdulillah I
started to give dawa and now I'm going
to give lectures throughout the world
and alhamdulillah most sweet things I
give dawa shahada
New Zealander were young man 18 years
old first time in Christ church I was
giving a talk first time in Christ that
there was a public talk he came to know
what is Islam the topic and he make
shahada on the middle of the public talk
which I learned from Dr. Zak night how
to give shahada on public talks.
Alhamdulillah I'm I'm been blessed with
many activities that we do. I'm the
founder and president of Islamic
Propagation Society International IPSI
supposed to be IPCI but alhamdulillah we
have have to change because of the
government requirement we puted Islamic
propagation society international. We do
lot of program public talk and etc. But
the most important thing I'm came here
to learn from our beloved ortor the
greatest ortor of the century a scholar
of the comparative religion Dr. Zakir
Knight and the beauty of Dr. Zak night
he can quote with with all from his
memory which I amazed if he were to
quote from the Bible and from the Quran
is okay but he started to quote from the
Hindu scripture that is really amazing
that's really amazing and I'm always a
student and I come here to learn until
the end and to be the best and the
excellent D and the most effective D and
bring the message of Allah to all
mankind inshallah please make that dua
alhamdulillah
Alhamdulillah.
I would like to greet you with Islamic
greeting. The greeting of peaceal.
My name is Wong Wong. There is a given
name given by my parents and I embraced
Islam in 2005 and I have choose Feros
Wong Wong as my name. I am from Koala
Lumpo, Malaysia. I was born as a
Buddhist and currently I am the founder
and the president of multi-racial
reverted Muslim. I used to play football
professionally and I used to represent
Malaysia squads under 17 in 1998 and
under 21 in 2002. So sport is something
that I used to do and I still love to do
it now. And alhamdulillah despite being
a Muslim since 2005 I only a practicing
Muslim praying five times a day from
2005 until 2011. If you were to ask me
what is Islam or what is the pillar of
Islam or articles of faith during that
period of time, I might not be able to
answer you to tell you frankly and
alhamdulillah by the grace of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala plans and I have been given the
opportunity to met Sheh Husseini
and after the meeting with Sheh Husseini
and that is the turning point of my life
where I start to do dawa and
alhamdulillah
before this I am a senior account
manager in one of the public listed
company in Malaysia and I have resigned
since 2013 and involved in dawwa
full-time and ever since there's no look
back and alhamdulillah by the grace of
Allah again I have been selected I have
been chosen to become the host of a TV
show the Tamu masid in China where we
are doing a shooting five weeks in China
to visit the mosque in China and also
alhamdulillah Azu been selected to
become the moderator the host of one of
the interfaith dialogue in Malaysia in
TV Ahijra as well called dialogue
harmony and in other media as well and
why focus and my expectations in this
dawa training program inshallah first
and foremost is to gain the pleasure of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala and of
to become a better and effective Di and
to share Islam to everyone and to
encourage and to inspires every single
people just like how Husseini inspired
me to become a D and to be involved in
dawa and that is my goal and that is my
intention.
Alhamdulillah.
Dear brothers, I was actually born in
India, Mumbai. I'm from here. U my my
name is Ashi Kureshi. My father's name
is Af Kureshi. I have uh two daughters
and a son. And alhamdulillah, my
schooling was from a convent school. I
went to a Catholic school, a common
school. Uh and when I finished my
schooling, alhamdulillah, at the age of
17, I left for Switzerland. I went to
Switzerland to study hotel management.
I did hotel management for a couple of
couple of years in Switzerland. Traveled
Europe. Alhamdulillah. Allah gave me the
opportunity. Uh got to got to learn
French while I was there. Got to go to
Chita Vaticano in Italy, the the house
of the pope. Uh since we're talking
about dawa, so I got to see the the
Christian world a little bit.
Alhamdulillah. I came back to India and
then I went back to United States of
America. I got my degree in uh four
years degree in hotel and uh business
management. Uh after I finished my
degree, I worked for one of the uh
biggest casinos uh in the world. It was
called as Foxwoods Resorts and Casino. I
was in management. I was not in gaming,
but I was in the resort part of the
casino. Alhamdulillah. Uh Allah
protected me there. Uh alhamdulillah.
And uh after working for a few years in
the casino, uh I was never satisfied
with uh the the job conditions, the
atmosphere, uh I didn't have the job
satisfaction. Uh but somehow,
alhamdulillah, Allah took me out of from
uh from that sin city. Let's put it that
way. And Allah always protected me.
Alhamdulillah, after I left the job in
the casino, I must have spent maybe 15
years in United States. I came back to
India.
after I came back to India within maybe
uh a couple of years I got to meet Dr.
Zakarak alhamdulillah and so Allah is
you know I never made a you know a
decision as to which direction I was
going but Allah kept on bringing me to
the right direction alhamdulillah
uh so he I met Dr. is actor and he
offered me a job with him to work with
him in IRF. I worked with him
alhamdulillah I I worked personally with
him very close with him but uh the thing
was Dr. Zakanik, he he works very hard.
Let's be honest here. He he's a hard
worker. He's a perfectionist. He's a
tough boss, you can say. Alhamdulillah.
And uh mashallah. And he would sleep
maybe 3 hours a day. I couldn't do it,
you know. I couldn't cut it. It's 3
hours, 4 hours a day sleeping. Not not
good for me. So I requested Dr. Zakayak
and he he allowed me to be in IRF and
work as a DI as well as a guest
relations manager. So for the last seven
years I've been in IRF working as a DI
as a guest relations manager and giving
dawa to people one-on-one.
Alhamdulillah. At the same time Zakir
Dr. Zak has been very very helpful,
supportive to me and I want to take this
opportunity because I've never really
thanked him and this is not to score any
brownie points but uh to be honest that
he's been very helpful to me personally
and uh professionally. So I really want
to thank him and I want to thank him for
giving me this wonderful opportunity to
be here with such beautiful people and
uh inshallah be a much better effective
D in the future and maybe bring is to
Islam and Muslims. Having said that most
importantly I want to thank Allahawajel
for bringing me here and I want Allah to
reward all the brothers who are here
most importantly Dr. Zak and all the
people that are working here inshallah.
So may Allah make this very fruitful for
for us and may Allah give us a class so
we can do this without any
Alhamdulillah.
Great dice,
doctors, scholars, and to all those
watching at home. I greet you with the
most heartwarming and blessed greetings
brought about from Prophet Adam. Salam
to Prophet Noah, Moses, Jesus, to
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam peace be upon them all.
Before
coming on to this stage,
I am totally clueless on how to
introduce myself.
I've never talked publicly
to a large audience. So, inshallah,
Allah bless me with the uh flu fluency
in speech to address all of you.
My story may not be as uh interesting as
the others,
but
how I came to this path is uh rather
uh life-changing events as to what the
world is uh experiencing.
My name
is Muhammad Hisham bin Ahmed Haniman.
There is a mixture of Chinese, Malay,
and even German. So, Haniman is the
German name. Others know me as brother
Sha.
So
from a young age
I was always uh you know as a normal kid
playing around
uh talking to friends with from all
backgrounds and races and religions.
I have no
qualms about you know mixing together
but somehow watching on the news there
is always a distinct
uh effort to separate us saying oh he's
black he's white he's yellow I I didn't
uh take note of that I grew older still
got into u
uh secondary school and then uh took a
diploma in business thereafter uh
banking and finance economic and finance
and then
something happened on the news that is
I don't know whether it's a plane and it
hit the twin towers in New York innocent
people were killed and that woke me up I
wanted to know Why? Why? Why? Why?
So from then on
I started researching.
I started looking into what happened
and alhamdulillah
by the grace of Allah
I found Islam.
So before this I was actually uh
learning and studying uh what the tawis
were practicing, what the Buddhists were
practicing, what the Christians were
practicing.
Uh
mashallah
I have no idea that there was so many
similarities and that was brought about
by the great Dr. Zakai. Alhamdulillah.
So from these events
I started to you know connect the dots
how this religion connects with this
this and this
and in the end I found out that there
was only one creator after allahala.
Same way as the buildings went down,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
It was the same way that uh my faith
increased and eradicated all the
disbelief and all the misinformation
that has been uh presented in the media.
I pray to Allah
that he bless all of us with this uh
opportunity to become
great preachers, great advisers to bring
the human humanity at large together
inshallah.
ill.
[music]
Allah.
Allah
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
>> [music]